the yankees going for three in a row
against the orioles the sweep of the
series but jameson taion he has not
fixed in a big league game
707 days david
yeah we get a shot at jameson tonight
i'm all for that mullins is ready
3-2
tries to punt with two strikes
and pumps through it to strike out
anthony sattandare here is the 2-2
swung on and he popped him up in the
infield coming down as torres behind the
mound to make the catch
and tyonne has a terrific first inning
first with two outs in the bottom of the
first
grounded up the middle and threw for
basic calves couldn't get there
labor torres will go to third and that's
a single for stanton and the yankees
have runners on the corners with two
outs for clint frazier
means ready 2-2 on the way
center field
mullins back he's going to make all
three put outs this inning
two of the books nothing nothing the
left hand hitter rio ruiz
fly ball left field gardner drifts back
one out here's freddie galvez the payoff
pit
popped up long run for urshela then he
makes the play for the second out
geo's got to cover some ground in the
shift
second baseman ramon urias here's the o2
struck him out swinging high fastball
out of the zone
he likes to look at what he's done so
far tonight meredith nine up nine down
fourth inning top the lineup of
frederick mullins
drives the ball out towards right field
heading back getting up and it's out of
here
cedric mullins answers with a solo blast
to right
o's tie it up one all in the fourth
anthony santander to the plate
he swings and drives the ball out
towards right heading back towards the
bullpen and this one is out of here
send it over the fence anton dare those
take a 2-1 lead in the fourth here's a
2-2 to mount castle
and his strike three right on the
outside corner
and there are two
two swinging
so he bounces back from the santander
home run to strike out mount castle
and franco
jameson
they'll face pedro severino here in the
fifth
strike three just clipped the outside
corner three strikeouts in a row for
tylenol galvez switched it to batting
left 02
struck him out swinging he struck out
seven his last five outs have been
strikeouts and that's going to be his
last battery picture for the yankees
heart throwing righty nick nelson
three two runner goes strike three
is down looking to the bottom of the
sixth inning and one away here's sanchez
rocket face it
down the left field line it'll go into
the corner right out there by my castle
as sanchez picks up a double
it's a nice job by sanchez to keep this
baseball fair sanchez with the tying run
at second one out here's george
fly ball right center
[Music]
mullins makes the cats tagging as
sanchez here's the throw it's cut off
gary sanchez never hesitates you're
going all the way now tanner scott
appearing for the second time this year
rick gardner at the plate the next pitch
swing and a miss
got him with a hundred miles an hour
triple digits for out number three of
the sixth inning and tanner scott using
just three pitches strikes out brett
gardner one away and a runner on at
first orioles with a 2-1 lead over the
yankees in the bottom of the seventh
tanner scott faces aaron hickman 3-2
big swing and a miss up top at a slider
strikeout number two for tanner scott he
sets two down in the bottom of the
seventh that brings up john carlos
stanley
2-2 swing and a miss it's another slider
three straight rings up stanton base
runner left stranded 2-1 orioles lead it
at the end of seven bring up gary
sanchez and the pitch
drill to left field going back mount
castle
it goes up against the wall and sanchez
for some reason is just at first if
sanchez
did not run hard because it looked like
the ball was right at bow castle anyway
there's the tying run talkman pinch runs
there's archella
that one is driven into left center
field that ball is going to be in there
cut off in the gap by mount castle here
comes topman they're sending him home
here's the throw here's the play at the
plate he's safe the game is tied at two
this is just one heck of a baseball play
all the way around geo
on the hanging slider laces in the gap
mount castle cuts it off does his job
hits the cutoff man does his job
galvez does his job
the top and does his just a little bit
better and outruns the whole thing as
santander will start the inning at
second base
right back to green he knocks it down
and a scoop by bruce
that was big
gets the out at first and keeps on dare
at third and they're going to challenge
i agree he's out so here's severino
grounded to taurus fields
in the dirt and it gets by bruce and a
run scores
labor torres with a big error to give
the orioles a 3-2 lead
three infielders on the left side for
higashiyoka wayne is the tying run he's
in second
that's going to tie the game well let's
see wade's coming home here's the throw
from santander he is
in there ty
the speed of wave just got him in and we
have reached the 11th inning at yankee
stadium chance cisco pitch hitting for a
res
[Music]
little flare
and it's going to fall in and the
orioles take the lead so a pinch hit
base hit rbi for chance cisco
and the orioles on top four to three
orioles lead the yankees bottom of the
11th inning and paul frye will take over
he'll inherit the placed runner at
second base goes trying to put this one
to bed once and for all shella goes to
second base
rick gardner comes to the plate and
there's the bunt fly off the mound
[Music]
[Applause]
comes up firing here's the throw it's
there and he
got him
a block off win cuts down or shella at
the plate